a cereal a soup no cereal is not a soup
cereal it's a cereal i guess milk being
the
the liquid in it was my problem with it
being a soup but
i guess that you can have different
liquids in your soup whatever so
i call it a breakfast soup man a soup
yeah
no not at all it's cereal
uh no yes soup
which is not well i mean in the bahamas
we feel kind of warm sometimes but
we got captain crunch with cream and
water you can heat it up just a little
bit
i've been hearing people don't know
that's fire i don't know if y'all do
that here in the states
uh you can't have soup for breakfast so
i'm saying no
oh a soup oh absolutely not absolutely
not no
it's soup oh it's not a soup
nah cause you really just swallowed soup
you gotta chew
on the cereal ah nah i'm not going for
that one cereal is not a suit
don't reach for it what color is a
mirror
that's a trick question
[Laughter]
mirrors are a
chrome a reflective chrome
i guess i don't think
it's great mirrors the color of whatever
you're seeing they're clear
mirrors are a mixture of all of the
colors and that's
where the reflection comes from
whatever color like that's in front of
it
i guess clear y'all funny
if i drop soap on the floor is the soap
dirty or is the floor clean
the soap is definitely dirty the soap is
dirty
you see the dirt get on you so and you
gotta wash it off
it depends on if the floor is dirty if
the floor was dirty before you dropped
it and now the soap is dirty but the
floor is clean before you drive through
and i guess you just cleaned it up a
little more the soap is dirty
i think you'd have to um like actively
clean the floor
this soap is different dairy uh
both the soap's kind of dirty well it
depends are you in the bathtub
uh so so dirty yeah it's so sturdy and
the floors
i feel like soap can't be dirty though
the floor is clean the floor speed
the soap is dirty the soap is dirty the
floor
is nasty so when you drop the soap on
the nasty dirty floor the soap becomes
nasty and dirty
um the soap is still clean dude i don't
think sobe is dirty
the soap is dirty it's so dirty because
the floor is already
soaked during the game leave it at that